hello there guys we have got some really
exciting news regarding the obi-wan
kenobi show
and that is that hayden christensen is
returning
as da freder this is insane guys we've
all been wanting hayden christensen to
return for such a long time
and he is finally returning to the star
wars universe
i also really hope we will see hayden
christensen as anakin skywalker so
possibly in some flashback sequences
that ob1 has
which i really think we'll see i think
there'll be many flashback sequences of
obi-wan
struggling on tatooine um having some
nightmares and flashbacks and
i think that's when we'll see um anakin
skywalker and possibly some other cameos
possibly from commander cody which was
actually rumored we could even see
qui-gon jin return as a force ghost and
possibly even master yoda communion with
obi-wan kenobi because if you remember
at the end of revenge of the sith
yoda was saying he had more training for
obi-wan on tatooine
to help him commune with qui-gon jinn so
i think we definitely see that in this
series
but the main thing i'm really excited
for is that hayden christensen is
finally back so that is exciting but
talking about story-wise the only
confirmed detail we have so far apart
from
hayden christensen is that this series
will begin
10 years after the dramatic events of
revenge of the seth
and of course guys the show is coming to
disney plus so yeah guys what do you
think about this news
i'm incredibly excited and i think the
future for star wars is bright so please
let me know in the comment section below
what you think about all of this news
and i'll catch you guys in the next
video
[Music]
you